okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p it's
been a long time since we heard from
furious angry trumpets Jimmy from Philly
I know some people in the audience like
Jimmy from Philly others don't
it's been so long since we heard from
him that I want to give you a little bit
of a peek behind the curtain into my day
envision this I wake up I come
downstairs I make my breakfast I make my
cappuccino I bring it over and sit down
in front of my computer and it's time to
see who called in overnight we've got 50
60 70 voicemails that came in overnight
at two one nine two david p uh-oh I see
seven voicemails in a row from Jimmy
from Philly what's going on I'm just
gonna play them for you the imagery is
I'm sitting there with my cappuccino
listening to this take a listen
skater Jimmy from Sony when are you
gonna unscannable ban me from YouTube
and I don't want to hear that your
moderators date believe yeah you tell
them to do it they on do it right come
on David you're running the show here
you have a team on the hell works man
yeah well when we gonna get this shuttle
on the road here David what are you
waiting for
so again shadow bear I have no idea what
Jimmy's talking about and he was just
relentlessly calling in about this take
a look at this David came in from Philly
I see him still shadow dance on your
lives yeah nice no idea what he's
talking about and just continuing to
Porter's give me from Kelly why are you
gonna take me off shot oh and that why
don't you an got cut off here's another
Jimmy give me buco you don't have the
balls to announcer like joint you are so
disingenuous it's like I have made my
call I have no clue of what Jimmy's even
talking about and then I'll just do one
more there were more but I'll just do
one more for you so so you couldn't call
me out David and you're not gonna have a
Collins yeah I want my money back David
I don't even know what money Jimmy's
talking about the last I was aware of
was Jimmy had a member
ship which he canceled months ago I
think he said because he was he was
getting laid off or something like that
so that's a typical day for me
preparing for the show I I don't I don't
envy me please don't envy me we're gonna
have a great bonus show today we are
going to talk about Texas is now saying
just stay home
Texas is wide open right like Texas
opened early and on paper Texas is open
but the governor now that they're having
5,000 new cases a day the governor is
saying just stay home in Texas we will
talk about how in July that enhanced
unemployment that $600 a week boost for
coronavirus is coming to an end and
we'll talk about the economic
implications and we will also talk on
the bonus show today about a state court
decision that says police don't police
are not able to force you to unlock your
phone it's a very interesting case when
it comes to what it means to do a search
or seizure and all of those stories and
more will be on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
join pakman.com remember that I am now
book a bull on Kameo I'm David Pakman on
cameo and lastly don't miss the daily
audio podcast you can take it with you
anywhere in your favorite podcast app
don't miss it record day yesterday for
the audio podcast very very exciting for
me